your hunger will drive you everyday
hunger maintain a hunger hungry
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can be hungry and
as always guys as you're watching the
videos if you see something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
if you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well
[Music]
when you think about life everybody
wants to prize but nobody wants to
process everybody wants to championship
but nobody wants to day-to-day everybody
wants to win game but nobody wants to
put in the work that it takes to win
games and the Bible talks about in
Proverbs that says the laborers an
appetite works for him and his hunger
drives her more the labourers appetite
works for him and his hunger drives her
more
and so my question to you all is what's
your appetite for winning because if you
have an appetite for winning your hunger
will drive you every day your hunger
will take you to the weight room your
hunger will take you pasture or to your
hunger we've taken pasture our position
your hunger will take you past adversity
your hunger would take you past a trial
or tribulation your hunger will take you
to that fourth quarter when it's four
zeros on that clock you have company
that Bucky you have given everything you
had in that game since the certain
mindset man when you attack this thing
the game of football
it's not about skill that's what people
mr. Bobo in this game is not about it
has nothing to do it skill it has
nothing to do with a 40-yard that's it
has nothing to do it jumping a 40 inch
vertical what this game is about it's
about well that's it
it's not about skill this game is about
well and so the moment that you make up
in your mind the day that you wake up in
your mind that you're going to play this
game for God to give everything you got
to it you can't help but to give
everything you've got and that's the
moment that you realize this game has
nothing to do with skill I've seen
plenty of talented guys fold I've seen
plenty of turns the guys getting hit in
the mouth and they didn't rolling I seen
plenty of talented guys get punched in
the face and they go back to the
sideline they stand beside the coaching
they don't want it no more they make up
excuses I see him turning of talented
guys they ran a 4248 bench press 325
pounds when 31 came up they tapped their
helmet to come out of the game that has
nothing to do what skill ask yourself
what if no one ever bought any of my
work what if I'm never gonna sell a book
or publish a book or a short story are
you gonna continue to write and if the
answer is yes because I have to do then
yeah then you are a writer and whether
you're selling out I can't know but if
they're stories and you that have to get
out and want to put them down in the
paper with it whether you ever get the
affirmation of a contract or a book in
your hand or being on the bestseller
list if you still have to tell your
stories then then your writer if you can
give it up then then it probably would
be an act of sanity to learn accounting
or something like that how much further
can you go that's a really good question
and I don't know the answer to that I
don't have those types of goals if I
want this number you know I just have
the goal of I want to play well at this
term and I want to win this tournament
you know and I don't want to win this
tournament and when I wake up one
morning and I just absolutely do not
want to go on the court or have no
motivation of going to court then that's
what I'll be good for me has acting
turned out to be all that you wanted it
to be it's incredible it's incredible
you know I I never knew that I could do
it as a career I never knew I it was the
first memory that I had it's the first
thing I can think of as saying I want to
be an actor to my parents and if I
hadn't lived in Los Angeles and been in
such close proximity to sort of the
mecca of moviemaking if I didn't have
parents that said okay we'll drive you
to auditions we didn't have the economic
means to you know move camp from Idaho
to Los Angeles because some snotty
ten-year-old kids is how I mean it
we did it night after school I got to go
on auditions but it was always and I've
said this before it felt like an elite
group of people and it felt like I would
never belong to them so once I got the
opportunity to to for example get the
movie this boy's life
with Robert De Niro I said wow now I'm
able to not be able to steer the course
of my career I might be able to have a
career similar to these guys that I'm
you know I so admire and that I knew
what 15 years old was the biggest gift
in the world and that that's that's
never left me you know I've never I've
never that that thirst or that hunger
for wanting to give one great
performance that I'm truly satisfied
with or being one movie that I said I
love this film is something that I don't
know will ever be quenched I don't know
and that's I think that that's a good
thing because it keeps making it keeps
pushing you you know because it is
constantly dissatisfied in other words
Paul Newman told me that any successful
person in any field Oh in discussing
their career doesn't use the word luck
is a lot oh yeah he's absolutely right
yeah so you consider yourself lucky very
lucky but you have to talent to meet the
luck right somebody hands you the ball
and you run you know I mean and if you
get hit you get hit or maybe you make it
through you never know but I mean I I
just know that somebody handed me the
ball at a certain point and I was hungry
enough to keep running and I'm still
running I maintain a hunger but not an
ambition you know I I am very happy to
explore all possibilities with a
character and and really you know dive
in to to the roll I mean even to the
point of where you know Disney wanted to
wanted to fire me they wanted to fire
you from Pirates yeah because they
couldn't understand what I was doing you
know they didn't understand the
character they were actually were
contemplating subtitling with
you know I mean success I don't I don't
think it's something you can I don't I
don't think you can you know describe
successes you know it's it's acts
because it means different things to
different people
and there's different levels of success
I'd say we're starting to enjoy success
now I bought my mom a brand new car for
her birthday
I was definitely a dream come true for
me that was a level of success but then
you look at jay-z you know I'm saying
he'll he'll tell you a billion is
success and he makes it to a B or
whatever you know I'm saying like he's
way way way up there in the stratosphere
so this is just like I don't I don't
tell myself I made it I don't tell
myself I'm successful I tell myself I'm
hungry and I want to keep it on I didn't
have an easy experience I didn't have
come in as a top-rated recruit I didn't
come in with the opportunity to play
right away I had to earn it and you know
what the greatest honor I've ever
received as a player is in my fourth
year and my fifth year I was named team
captain that to this day is the single
greatest achievement I've ever had as a
football player because the men in this
room chose me to lead their team and
these were my best friends these were
the guys that that knew that I'd like to
work that knew that I loved football
that knew that I loved to play that knew
that I wanted to be the quarterback from
Michigan and all the lessons that I've
learned here on State Street and in the
big house that's still what I bring to
practice today and after 14 years I love
the game more than I've ever loved it
cause historically I think about that
run all the time Oklahoma City is all
about
first off natural disasters and Oklahoma
City bombing just to put it out there to
be real I mean that's what the city was
known for and to win
Western Conference championship with a
group of young guys by the cities I've
never seen anything like it
there's something I'm always gonna
remember but the Thunder lost the NBA
title to the Miami Heat
and LeBron James in five games Kevin
Durant was second again and there to
console him was the same person who made
him do push-ups in the middle of the
night 12 years earlier long hug with
your mom after you all didn't make it
there you hugged her and long in a heart
yeah well first thought that was just I
could thank you and my mama she was
always at the right time
and a lot of people got on me for crying
in front of national TV but we wanted
something that bad it was just like I
didn't care I do everything I do I love
jet skiing going out with quad bikes
motorbikes surfing rock climbing pretty
much anything with an engine yeah I try
to do as many things that I can I'd like
to do water skiing or do wakeboarding
and want to skiing so I pretty much do
quite a few things but those are the
things that I do too and my dad would be
like you should be doing in those things
because you race off on one car you
don't need to do it but when you're not
racing you need something to keep that
that adrenaline and that hunger going
where the died of the flag all right you
just swung she trying to feed our
families yo don't say it's a job it
ain't nowhere somebody just felt like
doing I did it you know saying it was
hungry everybody's gotta eat don't say
not found some I was good at
I'm just trying to flip it you know keep
it going I'm sorry I'm trying to slack
at all toughen up about people's my
borough my family I thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know which of the clips are the
biggest impact on you and why leave it
down in the comments I'm gonna join in
the discussion I also want to know how
are you being hungry what do you do in
your business in your life right now to
stay hungry leave it down in the
comments I also want to give a quick
shout out to Charlie funk Thank You
charlie for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and sending that tweet out
about it I really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon